all right and we are live the last word
with Lord kognito anybody's returns hot
campfire talk and man this feels like
flashpoint long man
strap in everybody we are gonna be here
for a little while if you're taking us
with you on the go that might be the
best way to go audio on the go is gonna
be a long one today so yeah like holy
crap that's been it just in case you
didn't think we were gonna have much to
talk about there might have been a
couple of leaks here
apparently Dillon took over Luke's job
of breaking his keyboard mm-hmm and oh
my god like so much so much to talk
about
yeah tons tons of talk about Manny I
mean it is only talked about about this
offline just like even forsaken you know
I'm saying and taking King I can't
remember this just sure of sheer volume
of information like almost week after
week it's just I've never seen could you
imagine if they held all this stuff I
try to throw it on a lot like we'd be no
he'd be reading still oh you'd be like
trying to boot up the game be but hold
on I got to read a book first yeah I'll
be with you in two days
no I'm gonna no life this book exactly
we're like this thing is a phased
rollout that had to be done so yeah man
this isn't a so lot to discuss lot going
on been playing a bit I'll talk about
myself first cuz I'm having fun playing
a bit man on back in my black Homburg I
I finally got my Izanami I finally got
that quest bro oh I feel for you guys
you guys that did that when it was in
its Hey and that now you'll be lad I
could see why people want to throw a
control that the screen like we're two
of us over here with this gun here this
oh yo they made something so crazy their
date like the community just was stumped
they said let it go so that was that got
the armor pieces I mean it was just so
many steps um you know that I was just
like wow this is a long quest you know I
mean sorry
the ornament for it got thrown in you
know them so now the next step would be
getting my behind in the UM Minaj rock
when I fix I want the catalyst now I
gotta finish it off but yeah it's been a
lot of that I've been doing the
Registrar salute to you for helping me
with the shattered throne backpack
Edition yeah that was cool and yeah
Metta right now what I'll be rocking
right now right now it's all about all
I've been doing on my juju move stoking
all my Juju's following my PvP game but
um yo smg's right now ma'am 900 900 I
got I got the curated bug out brag and
I'm causing problems man it wasn't proud
I'm feeling good both I killed clip
feeling good right now
that's cogs I'm starting to segment cogs
load out of the week yeah yeah so we're
doing that we do a bug out we're doing
juju you know and then um heavy right
now because of mountaintop got never
feel we're throwing back up I got it I
got an outrageous fortune I don't have
your God roll swarm it works know what
you I did a little bit of nightfall
stuff or have you contributed to the
Mars event sir I have been get yourself
in there man get in there help no go do
your nightfall parts all I gotta say if
you were listening to this and still the
weakest I'm not a third I've got a guide
out there esoteric as a guide out there
for the 5 minute nightfall I've got a
longer one but hopefully you'll survive
that one either way do your night falls
that's pretty much all that's remaining
is the two night falls and killing hive
they knocked out escalation protocol
they knocked out the override
frequencies in two days mm-hmm like they
were over 50% on those like on day one
and even Bungie was like damn and then
two days those are knocked out in the
night falls of a slow one so everybody's
living in escalation protocol and now
it's like now we got to do the night
falls and it's like oh so yeah those
remained did those streamed while I did
those had a good stream doing that yes
so let's see I beat
the final boss in a remnant okay
yes I made it 101 uh I did that one solo
cuz my friends were like yeah go see if
you can try it then I just as soon as I
started doing it was like alright I have
to figure this out so I did that by
myself um it's a really cool game
remnant is cool and the thing is like I
could go back in play like seven
different bosses I haven't seen nice so
as you go through that game it's it's
just I don't know it's it's a fun
shooting Dark Souls Division you've got
some leveling up to it different
abilities that you'll unlock with your
guns that have cool things there's a lot
more to that than I thought and I think
it might be like 40 bucks it's so much
so worth it like it is a really fun game
is it perfect no but is it hella fun
absolutely like if you want to break
like remnant is really good there's a
lot of stuff come in obviously Monster
Hunter came out there we've got
Borderlands come in but I'm tempted by
it I know I like Buster it's been so
long since I've played it like and I
haven't really played on PlayStation
much in a while anyway it's like I mean
it probably would play it on controller
because that's where it feels natural
but it's been so long since I played if
I just tried to boot up I had decent
gear I'd probably be okay to go into
like the ice bore and stuff but I'd be
so out of practice and that's that's a
good like couple hundred hours again if
you start that thing over so I just
don't know which one I'm gonna have the
time for and I think if I do anything
separate it'll be Borderlands so coming
yeah man good stuff man getting those
other games in during this little yeah
had a little break I mean I got I grind
it out there's one night I think it was
you were there and it was turning them
all and I got all my pvp weapons so much
like how you did that that's kind of
nice all recorded together so it's just
kind of like kind of stepping back I put
my I got my couple night falls in did my
escalation did like five overhead
frequencies like did my quick peace this
week I didn't mind you got to do yours
no I have to do it anyway because um you
got to do at least one nightfall to get
the emblem yeah yup I got to get the
exact and then the UM I want the emblem
and it was something else I was working
on and I got requires some night for
work so I can knock two birds out with
one stone just get it done so yeah
definitely
I will be in the I was just being lazy
plus again I was determined to get
Izanami I was like I'm getting this done
I don't care how long it's gonna take I
just need it out of my life like that
it's be done just wanted it out well as
you can say that one's done
but yeah the Mars community event has
been going I know we probably talked
about this briefly the last week how
much do you think it's really worth it
yeah we have a little emblem we have the
menagerie chests menagerie chess
potentially getting added I don't know
if they're gonna finish it today which
is when if they finished it today at
reset that we could actually get the the
first chest like bone right but I don't
know if you'll get that this week but
probably starting next week is when
we'll start seeing those so we'll have
double drops going forward and then at
least for the rest of this season for
the additional weeks we'll get a few
extra so that last week if you want to
go run a little menagerie then yeah
that'll be the time to do it and little
go back to having I think to permanently
though once this season is over
yeah I think people more incentive get
up a name and I love the activity I love
the idea but people that you know they
don't want to do all that just for you
know one little thing especially when
they had riches before so you know I'm
looking for two so that's most of what's
going on currently but we got a ton of
news about what is coming in is if you
jaw so would you prefer to start with
packs or packs and kind of the exotics
involved there do we want to go spoilers
or leakage it let's go leakage because
I've actually everybody spoiler
territory but um yeah man now we got it
we gotta talk about it because um I've
actually I kept my head to the ground
like I wasn't I was I was an ostrich
mole like I was not I could blue it fell
through Twitter and I was just like oh
there's a new exotic yeah yes I didn't
take long
spoiler warning for a little while if
you guys are not too keen on it skip
ahead like you know five ten minutes who
knows but we've got a couple
actual screenshots cuz people got to
play with the shadow keep build when
they went to pax I got to do I think it
was they did the gambit thing again and
then they got to do 3v3 elimination was
was the wager this time that was the
wager match their mode again keep so
coming back yeah but people were like
snapping screenshots and monitors
pulling up inventories checking
collections yeah before digging and it
started a couple things so we have first
this is good I know you go
I'm gonna save part of it for later cuz
that comes into all that little sense
we're gonna talk about okay all right
cool what's a unless you want to do the
sets now which we can cuz the the whole
patch changes or something else so all
right so we'll first start with the
weapons so some of you guys may have
seen from the preview there's like that
crazy void rocket launcher thing well
that is exactly what that's gonna be
it's called the Death Bringer and it's
big it's purple it is one of the most
unique profiles we've ever seen it does
look really cool it's got this big leg
kind of almost like bird mouth beak to
it basically the two perks are dark
deliverance and Dark Descent
the rocket wears a projectile that drops
powerful void orbs when it explodes and
players can also remote detonate the
rocket mid-flight the farther the void
orb falls the more damage they deal
interesting yeah so I don't know if it
looked like they were like flying around
and tracking but I didn't know if like
you have to be above like and then it
falls like a carpet bomb type thing like
dropping from below so I don't know like
that'll be that'll be interesting so
mm-hmm
that one looks really cool um everyone
on Twitter at Bungie seemed to call they
change their name to dollar sign machine
gun 0 dot name dollar sign that's the
new machine gun that is definitely very
unique so it's a hundred and twenty
rounds per minute so it is ultra slow
for a machine just slow yeah that's
oh there's even what's fixed times my
fixed I was like three some slow but I
mean this is laying people have
described this thing almost like a
linear fusion rifle to Wow equate it
yeah fixed odds is three
it's a third dad Wow that's slow so the
main part is pyro talks and rounds the
gun fires powerful explosive ammunition
it only has 13 rounds of the magazine
but does very high damage little brief
things I heard from different places I
was listening to like we're talking one
hit headshot two bodies whoa yeah
so it's gonna be quite powerful but
working in a very different way yeah
it's definitely gonna be very slow but
hard-hitting I mean the thing looks like
you're walking around like with you you
took this off of like a stationary
turret the barrel is just huge shame and
so big so yeah small clip big damage
definitely slow fire and there and then
we had the divinity trace rifle the one
that they have talked about before so
this is the exotic this is the raid
exotic apparently okay leaking already
yeah absolutely an arc trace rifle and
it's got two Burke's judgment causes the
weapon to create an aura around the
enemy that disrupts and weakens them
with some sustained damage and then it
sounds like a debuff it's a debuff so
there's you're you're doing damage and D
buffing while the rest of your crew can
go to town and the tenants causes
enemies enveloped in judgment to take
damage okay almost a support kind of oh
yeah I mean this will do damage but it's
definitely gonna be impact is ultra low
obviously stability is maxed magazine
what's the archetype again this is a
tracer eyeful this is a trace so it
basically sustained it's almost like
sustain tractor in a way hold it on
there yeah it makes a curt spot so you
if you hold it on there and there in
that aura everybody else is firing so
this will be like this will be your
support build as well so as we were
talking about previously with the art of
mech and have that like void grenade do
it this would be another way to do that
support build yeah this is this is
exotica legendary wattage that's exotic
ok cuz the reason why I was asked I was
like okay well maybe I was thinking you
get like creative and have lumina and
you can be real all support with it but
it's exhausted be cool but yeah
that'd be the open support bill but not
coach mmm
so yeah that's Divini those are the
three exotics that seem to have leaked
um there is some armor as well yes so
you've got the store for you for mr.
warlock over here we got storm dancers
brace warlock chest
when players defeat enemies with storm
trance they increase the damage of storm
trance
oh wait wait this is exotic flavor this
is exotic well bring that back bring
that Breyers let's meet enemies with
storm trance they increase the damage of
storm trance Oh
so we stack in baby we stat yeah so if
you I'm in transit you won't be able to
go crown of Tempest in this for like
ultra forever long yeah yeah if they do
transcendence at least on top tree I
think yes and then this one I don't know
if there's a couple ads you can kill
like or if you're killing enemies around
like a main boss or something like that
if you can get a collection either
you're just gonna like vaporize like a
major or something like that when you
kill some small ones definitely be doing
some power stuff there yeah it's cookies
gonna be how much the damage scaling is
going to be but um it sounds interesting
sounds interesting chest be okay so get
the Phoenix cradle Titan legs these the
ones we heard about with the SunZia buff
lasts twice as long and allies gain the
buff when they walk through Sun pot
spots like so if you've got sun spots
around the room everybody's buffed your
healing I'm giving them over shields
chunk and stuff around like Sun warrior
potentially has more of that support
role as well I mean you'll throw it but
it's more like hey throw it on you and
maybe one of the person and then you can
chuck them for a while but yeah
definitely give it a little more
benefits of sun work cuz I don't like
that does not get touched like ever
nobody is bottom tree at all 0 and then
the hunter one we've seen that before
that's the one with like kind of the
veil the glowing Bale so we've seen that
one before but those are the main
exotics that leaked we had some brief
people getting a feeling for the way
subclasses were working and we got full
details on the patch note so we'll go
over those in detail go over that yeah
but we're gonna jump to the bottom of
the table main reason is because when
you go to the bottom we get some armor
sets yeah and this is what you're
talking about right yeah that dress the
neon let's go so if you guys are
listening on audio or checking the video
out you are looking at our vases but if
you guys go to this week at Bungie for
the week of September 5th near the
bottom stay add to your collection they
show kind of the rotating gifts of all
the armor sets so for anybody in chat
and also for you since I've we've
probably got our own opinions and
warlocks and Titans may differ hunters
are kind of our hunters are a middle
vote but we'll have to see yes
so we're gonna go down the sets I don't
want to talk about where you're gonna
get them from and then I want your
thoughts on each set which ones you're
like cool I gotta have it
maybe I'm digging it digging it now
we'll see so first set we've got is the
one that we've seen in a lot of
promotions it's the dream main armor set
it's your spacesuits so you got your
space shaman I've got my astronaut and
the hunter is somewhere in between
somewhere in between
they're acquired from activities on the
moon probably something through Eris
just probably the legendary drops that
come in on the moon
we got spaces so what are you feeling
are you digging your warlock shaman now
that you get to see it in the full
rotating glory it's growing on me
I think gonna live it's growing on me I
hated it it's still stupid the Basques
is dumb I don't know what does that
relate to the moon besides the backpack
but it's like I don't know what that you
know it was feels like Aerys had some
say on that I feel like Eris influenced
the mask but you know it looks cool
Titans looking very cool feeling every
time I see y'all and I just think taking
that that's just no wonder if it's
honestly like just an altered model of
the taiko not mask is a little lower a
little shinier a couple tweaks do a
little rings on it but yeah it
definitely looks like this hiking up the
hunter it's fine I mean it's I mean yeah
that's fine like mine like the Titan
yeah I was like I look like a space man
so I'm cool with mine for the dream bein
set via the hunter
not my favorite the wool will go down
and without wasting any time I'm
honestly surprised they're showing this
yeah this is the big giant point of
contention
so yes the Garden of salvation raid
armor set acquired from the garden of
salvation raid mm-hmm
what do you think sir blowing it out of
proportion like I get it I remember that
set cuz I had the yellow wool for the
Warlock I'm biased I like to say it's
Osiris you already know where I'm at
so let's just get that out I am
compromised my baby's got that like I
love that set I love that it kind of
upgrades you got looks like I'm assuming
is that ornament or just um I'm like
wondering that's like a raid ornament or
if it's just straight-up gonna drop with
that glow yeah is that the glow is that
like a solstice chroma thing that we add
on you know it look it look cool it
looks like a combination of the you know
your Cyrus John but it almost feel high
of like a little you know a little dark
with it you know so I'm loving my war
like I'm firstly if a warlock let me
tell you the secret me if the warlock
helmet is lit I'm already I love that
help I feel like I'm a vex so I'm in you
know for the Goblin yeah I'm a goblin
straight up of a god I'm good what do
you feel about the the Titan I'm curious
for you you Titan now well where you at
with this one I mean first off um I mean
people like lots of reskin on the armor
but it's like reskin plus like four
hours of work like they took each piece
I mean you see the detail more in the
faces like there's a lot more intricacy
to every piece the glows are the glows
like this is we're talking about rise of
iron armor now this is the stuff we were
like begging for where's our crotas end
where's our taken King where our armor
with those crazy clothes and glowing
spectral pointy things and and we got
them so like first off it's freaking
sick like just the fact that they all do
warlock is looking good
I'm diggin it you guys that in the
hunter you both have some pretty big
pointy bins off your shoulders that I do
like
yeah I'm feeling a war like I'm all
about it so you know I'm biased man you
know Osiris is my man
this is vexed up I always liked the
vexes enemy I've always liked they
probably like they're probably like I
know everybody likes how fallen but I'm
the ops I'm like a cabal of vex kind of
guy you know cuz cabal they just big and
broad a they hit the gym I like the
Cabal and then the vex is just tech cool
we still don't know their motivations
and I'm feeling it man I'm all about it
this is art man yeah
so what some person pointed out though I
thought it was pretty funny they're
pretty sure every Titan in every one of
these pictures is a female cuz they're
like I don't think Big Boy can fit in
the frame times be hating me so they
body had to do that purpose you're right
your ass so I think when I see it on
like the male Titan with like kind of
that broader look I mean there are some
other ones later than I'm really diggin
I actually really like the hunter cloak
on this one just Kinnison has the next
kind of parts that are missing but
there's yeah and they repeat that and
the hunters shoulders and the hunter
helm with like the little like spoilers
going back in the top play I got a big
boy Titan but yeah hunters were like I
think Titans are probably I mean the
gloves look cool no matter what if I'm
wearing it cool room for sure but I
think I think Titan yeah I feel about
the Titan helmet all the way not that is
it's just average to me I don't I feel
like I feel like I've seen that model
and they made the top of it glow in the
back of the head but overall I would say
yeah I would probably put on the low end
of the three if I had to agree now which
I was like I know we kind of blew past
it are you gonna give this whole like
reskin controversy much effort thought
or otherwise or do you even do you care
do you think like reindeer should ever
be rescanned is it a big deal are you
like pitchforks and torches and picket
signs and lean on me I mean here's the
thing look if it was a straight carbon
copy to me this is what I call like a
remaster you don't say like this is a
real
imagining of something this is not
straight the same thing so you know look
if dudes you know feel away I get it you
know right Alma yes right all my [ __ ]
feel special but y'all can't tell me
that it don't look good you don't say
like to me he's like it looks good so I
don't know it to me is a whole bunch of
nothing I think honestly this is people
behind the scenes there are packs seeing
stuff they wasn't supposed to see so now
it's out there and now we got this big
stink about you know whether or not they
should be even attempting like that but
put it this way this how this is my
counter like this beloved d1 armor that
we still haven't seen like think about
like um the ORAC stuff and you know I'm
saying just like they'll take taken king
armor and stuff like this fly oh my god
these are assets that are not coming you
mean to tell me if they didn't bring
that back but reimagined it you wouldn't
be hot like people wouldn't be high you
know they'd like somebody was like just
throwing counterpoints at this too and
they're just saying it over this is
where you guys like freak out but there
was the strangers rifle which was
patient or which was what was the pulse
rifle and exotic oh yeah I'm gonna be
throw my yes and then if you go look at
what mercury guns same frame on all
three of them so I mean they'll use a
similar frame and that's a way sometimes
for them to add stuff in like their
weapon frames are ultra detailed
typically a lot of work goes into them
right I mean you go look at other weapon
frames and destinies are still some of
the damn best without a question here's
my other point to those dudes it's like
alright we're gonna act like destiny
hasn't been given us crazy-hot art
designs Crazy Heart weapon designs you
know all this flat stuff and then like
okay we're not allowed to reuse any
asset like ever like like we just come
through office of a rogue some real cool
sense man I can't go this was a trend
every season we see in this then if I
okay cool yeah going back in there to
create a little bit too much but to me
this is just like an inspiration I was
like they took like a skeleton of that
vet set but yeah man it looks no it
looks awesome like yes it has
like I have the VEX eye you have the
three but I mean outside of that like
yeah might have like a similar look but
I mean now this looks different enough
to me that I don't care but I haven't
seen the other one too long enough where
have I cared about wearing it when this
thing if I ever pick it up I'm like good
luck taking this thing off well that's
the big controversial set we'll move on
so you've got the substitutional armor
set this is acquired from seasonal
activities freeze season reward Winx and
the premium season pass so this which
looks like kind of like I don't even
know how to describe looks very dark
greenish kind of foliage not quite camo
but not only has that like fell out of a
forest look yeah I'm playing like a tree
yeah I feel like etz like I'm chilling
with devaron about the Cho's yep yeah
exactly
now this is the one in case everybody's
questioning this is one that comes from
the first like 30 or 35 ranks of the
free season ranks or you get these sets
at Rank 1 for the season Nass owners
gotcha okay remember guys season pass
includes the season ranked battle past
thing those are not seven I thought that
was clear but I've heard people like
mm-hmm questioning one or the other I
just want to be clear yes
there's the for the battle path sorry
tangent here but I've just had some
questions and other people I just want
to say it for us as well let's get it
the two levels of said battle paths or
season drinks and the top one is totally
free you could literally buy nothing
else of of destiny at this point in time
roll into October first and still work
on that yes you would not have to buy
season of the undying shadow keep
nothing new light players and people who
don't spend any more money on destiny
can still go through that free path or
in this set of armor earn a couple
legendary weapons and whatever else is
on that top rank which has some free a
few infusions and stuff if you buy
season of undying eat without shadow
keep for $10 you can do that and that's
gonna get you the premium set or the
premium path or if you buy shadow keep
it comes with seasons and dying that's
the premium path you get this set at
Rank 1
right so here's my question yes yes
let's get it what's that grind for the
solstice armor do you know that's gonna
be like tier 1 stats base level stats we
go I'm free firm oh I would bet if
they're giving you that free set it's
not gonna be high tier listen it's your
it's like here's babies for our 2.0 set
nah you can't throw that on me after we
grinded the way we grinded to get that
it's not gonna be raped here there's no
way it's gonna be that high instinct if
not gonna be that but it's gonna be
here's your first real force one two
bags if the say there's five levels one
to one is disrespectful for that if you
match the word you gonna give me a 1 you
go take that you get to take that set
you get to look like that in shadow keep
that suit you knew you were grinding for
cosmetics you're not getting a lead gear
from solstice there is no lace all right
check come on I want to know let's check
if Jo shine let's go let's go let's get
it right now let's who give us the last
word on this when you get your solstice
and you turn it in what team says like
say there's we don't know how many tiers
are but say there's five give us a
number one through five where you guys
think it's gonna be and vagabond oh ass
because he was actually one of the ones
I wanted to address that too it's like
let me get two XP 100 rank on the free
track yes they can
you can go three all the way up to 100
if you play just new like new light
players can go to 100 and season rank
but oh no what rank do you guys think
bloody one very vocal three with you
yeah all right well three would be good
but where do you think it I'm saying one
or two max man there's no way they're
gonna give you look forward it's all
about that cosmetic look man nah you
ain't go cosmetic me yet you have each
other you do get the boss his waist no
see the reason all say that wall you
guys are typing stuff in chat yes now
I'm gonna say thank you wishful thinking
yeah it's wishful thinking that's
exactly what it is not be optimistic no
I'm all right there's my argument yes
let's talk about all of shadow keep they
talk about all the
new difficulties and things like that
yes the solstice grind was literally
time there was not a lot of difficulty
and whatnot you're not gonna sit there
and devalue or grind it it's not threes
I see three to four drink later on so
that's okay I'm just gonna say it's like
if there's like three or four stats
there's gonna be basically it's on it's
on the low end for sure it's some
halfway up that tier tell you right now
there's no way it's gonna be high tier
stats there's no I'm not saying he's
gotta be no I don't say there's five to
say there's five or three if it's three
is one if it's five it's a max of two in
my opinion here's the deal at the end of
the day don't let this man fool this man
is this soloist he does everything
difficult is a walk in the park to a guy
like him he got all his three characters
so what's to do so long it's nice so you
know this wasn't time this is him
talking now it's time in folk let's
speak for I speak for the common folk
common folk guys we know this took a
long time there's not like not a robot
like ebon says there's not a robot like
esoteric this took a long time then they
wanted us to master working and all this
other stuff so at the very least howdy
don't you even think about give him a
slap in a one on this gear don't you
even the I'm at the range I'm out of my
pickup I'm out I will be out there on
the picket line if they do it one man we
gotta get it three two or three minimum
we probably put a vote up maybe wish it
to a vote last my podcast with us we're
gonna do we're gonna put a row to we're
gonna we're gonna double up on it I want
to see where this bet gonna go I like
this
but I will I will take the wager
expecting boxes to appear behind Katya
given my atomic wedgie wedgie
he is the 5% that one percentile guy
that does this in his sleep but you said
it you just said it while I was like
jokingly stepped away from the camera
you said it was just time it's not like
you're trying to solo shatter throne
you're like I don't care how many gambit
matches I don't care how many it's just
something it can be done with time it is
not a skill based actually not hey do we
knock it is not talking about the maths
work I don't even know if the master
works gonna carry over honestly that's
what I'm saying I'm talking about but
yes let me find the master but what
about the stats those are separate okay
I'm talking about stat tears say like as
we joked before like a helm stats here 1
through 5 like 50s 60s 70s 80s and 90s
first stats I'm saying you're gonna get
that base level stats here on this set
all I'm saying is whatever that that bar
is when they tell you that you got to
level it up if they throw a one on my
solstice gear when I do separate things
ok that's what I'm told you're talking
about 1 through tell an energy level so
you have yeah I don't know I'm talking
about your stats that tears I don't care
about the energy level that's just 1
through 5 they'll probably give you five
on that one just because it's okay yeah
that I'm not worried I'm talking about
your stat tears okay okay I see what you
talk about some sense this is not you
know Evelyn to like okay how did we have
an argument that long over something we
I said stats multiple times that's what
I'm talking about his stats that's your
energy of the armor very different so
anyway I think it's good okay so do you
think it's gonna be a Oh like a tier one
on stats like base level stats not be oh
okay now you just got a majors gotta
stick with the argument now yeah but
listen man this was an accomplishment
this is a celebration of everything we
did that's what that's what she told
that's what grandma told me when we know
you can look like that if you want to
that's gonna be your look man we'll see
Lucy they got they can't they can't
short-changed at base that's all I'm
saying I'm telling you like if you want
like five energy if you want your armor
half leveled up so you can start putting
stuff into it they'll probably end you
those five why not but that stat tier is
gonna be garbage probably so probably
yes so probably so apparently not from
it's the only Friday morning bundle
doesn't play because he's watching us
well thank you sir let us say no time so
here's the fun one everybody thought
might have been the raid stuff and this
is where my Titan I think wins all by
the way Oh yet I'm deathly moist so we
got the phenotype plasticity universal
ornament set for the season armor so you
get the season armor at Rank 1 on the
season rip like path Oh three people the
free track gets the armor but does not
get these ornaments these are part of
the premium track and I'm sorry but my
wings on my Titan Shh hello shout out to
the hunter looking like Bubba Fett Asano
like the hunter looks late like I saw
it's a what I like about it's a unique
look for the hunting you don't know have
a close that hood yeah no hood yeah it's
a cool I'm cool we've had looks like
that before not that I don't like I like
the low the double on the double finish
lit but y'all stole the show with
dum-dum wings oh yeah taking off you
know what you need to get with that look
I didn't even notice the arm like the
big grieve on is wrong oh yes I and it
sitting on the right - yeah that's yeah
it woke say the tailor like mega Josh
straight up yeah like a transformer
absolutely - is yo you know what helmet
will look apply to remember the UM the
president elders airplane helmet oh
that's not him that's still in destiny -
trust me it's still a dusty - really
taken up like that little backpack
antenna thing going up it's cool I like
that this is literally this could have
been arranged but this is like this is
what you get forgetting
either the season pass right this is
part of this track or were those people
who might be like paying to finish up
those ranks this is a cosmetic that
people are gonna be paying for I
probably or earning through time so then
we got the iron will armor set so this
the iron banner this is okay I wanted a
thought from this before okay yeah same
thing yeah this is probably the
lackluster of all the sets yo I am ban
have been on a decline yeah we got to
talk to the fashion people
I am bana the last three like hunters
clothes mm yeah that's odd to you
hunter looks the best even though he's a
little smudged in the face there it's
all mild it's just white and gray it's
like light you're a dark gray it's
there's like a tiny local accent on each
one you got like the iron banner logo on
the bottom of the like the cloak in the
butt towel but it's just it's very
subtle very so so they've gone away from
what I used to like with the the heavier
sets and then it just it just I don't
know where they go I don't know
everything in here if you're like ooh
let me the iron banner set and then
you're looking through this page you're
like oh I didn't I didn't do as well and
then we get down to the ever verse set
dude my Titan is gonna be ice skating
upside down yo you do yeah that's cool
but I've also got lions on my shoulders
I'm like little colour ornate oh this is
my set right here this is this is my
better shader on that and are you good I
kinda like the triple color but yeah you
can
I like the red the blue the white and
the gold plate I can dig it like on the
Titan because the white is still in
there like I'm the hunter it looks like
kind of a mess like me or the the look
of it the nature of like you gotta bows
in the back you got the double horn yeah
and then the warlock robe is a bit much
it's a bit or denis but I'm actually
digging it I'm getting like my little
rope samurai vibe going on right now I
was lying on my butt tell to hell yes
yeah lions fire I don't
more like boots though come warlock
boots I don't know what you can't ever
see your boots they don't matter
yeah but I could see those no we'll put
a shader on they'll go away you're fine
yeah just don't see it look like a it's
like a samurai up top with a cowboy in
the back automatically is a little off
with the boots but other than that I'm
covering up up to your Lea no shins
anyway you can't your feet your feet
don't matter
it look like a Gila and go punch your
fancy solstice stuff on your feet so you
can pull them on your boots and glow on
your boots they're right Shaq coming
shot let's go those upsets we got coming
Plus mm-hmm uh in addition to this the
currently available armor sets will drop
as armor 2.0 so you've gotten crucible
year one ornaments Vanguard you'll know
it's black armory gambit menagerie
menagerie chatter I suppose raids raves
destinations all of them and there will
be additional world drops that can be
found on legendary engrams that will
have and be updated to 2.0 so basically
everything it's gonna be 2.0 but these
are the ones that will be looking new
I want the seasonal ornaments for vex
raid set honestly looks pretty sick and
I'm diggin the spaceman so I'm cool with
a lot of that stuff I do all of this is
gonna be so cosmetic anyway so the big
freakout is some people honestly you're
gonna be getting like some people get
that raid armor set like the Garden of
salvation is still legendary guess what
ornament BAM make it look how you want
to so some people if they don't love it
you can pick to look however you want to
and that's kind of the whole Universal
ornaments anyway some people may be
looking like season of Optimus II who
knows like you've got a lot of options
there oh yeah so I guess I didn't freak
out that much about it maybe I should I
don't care I'm more I haven't been as
much about the fashion game for like 5
years cuz I've never been able to care
about it right cuz I'm usually not like
finding full I mean we had full race
sets that had benefit but I mean
generally especially in destiny -
fashion has not mattered for you okay
function hasn't mattered but now bi I
have a family
if out like that has like machine-gun
launcher and machine gun I'm like
reserves and then I have like a set
economist that looks completely awful
but it has machine gun perks yeah when I
go run my nightfall I'm running like
that I don't care how I look at the
struggle with that yeah that's a tougher
decision
nope don't care what I do is I'll keep
grinding until I find a better looking
piece that has those perks and then
break that down and waste cores and
that's me bro I got I got it I gotta
look trust me baby we gotta be out here
I can't be having that bummy almond
looking like mmm you got I got a look
good man I wall up it's a wall acting me
what I mean also for me like oMG said it
he's like so now I can take that
universal ornament set from the season
pass and I can go slap those wings and
put those with my glowing radar where
somewhere in there and be like hey go
look like this now that's gonna be cool
and then throw the shaders on there
maybe my knees in my head or glowing but
I got wings out the back like black
armor shader on all that oh dude yeah
like now I can mess with it cuz I don't
care but I'm not gonna sacrifice
function over fashion so I am excited to
fact that I could just mess with how I
look all the time and it's not gonna
mess with how I play so well it's about
time that you start looking better
everybody who sees my videos or a
screenshot of my characters like man you
look you you homeless right now homeless
Titan constantly we gotta get your gear
oh I get you looking right out here so
she can see what you looking with these
these weird-ass I got I got trash I
don't care so yeah armor 2 point is
gonna be cool because yeah you can I
keep you can mess around with all your
ornaments there's gonna be a lot more
the old ones the new ones shaders mix it
all up finally gets a mess with how I
look so I'm excited about that and I
really don't care about the rest
maybe I should maybe I should be like
tweeting out to dmg and Cosmo and indeed
and saying are they gonna stop playing
oh that's the question is is it to the
point
how you test them I was like yo is it
that you know what it's egregious I
think you should not play that's when
you see that's what you people picking
this up yeah I don't it seems just a
little ridiculous so all right we got
what else is going on we know the Mars
event we do have join the strike team
you would yeah die for this one I'll
tell ya I've gotta get in that you got
to get in that you gotta set your alarm
get in there so from 3 to 5 p.m. Pacific
time they're gonna be in the heroic
strike playlist on xbox live one person
at a time is gonna get paired up with
I'm gonna let you say that we've got big
names man on my blade King Kong Phil
Dominus Maximus fencer Xbox is only
begotten Son the Savior told y'all man
you know what this feels good though
because uh one like I've always told you
guys Phil is the biggest and two you
know like I said we just had Gamescom
symbolically it meant so much to have
fun G on that stage the history you know
I mean and then getting out of the
PlayStation exclusivity deal it's like
you know your ex came home for a little
bit you could speak in terms
everything's cool
so um yeah man I mean shut up [ __ ] about
no what's Xbox oh yeah you're not going
back to Xbox you know frame rate you
know no POV but it was about you know
give him back to the class yeah
Larry so salute um what you call it uh
Pete Parsons as well man like Gaston you
know saying so just see them in it
hardcore you know playing you know
destiny and this this is really
I'm definitely trying to get in on that
I will be lighting it up you know saying
Tuesday I will set my alarm
I got to get on to talk with Hale gonna
be there five six six to eight pm right
when you go to work or something like
that I'm sure oh man I've got in there I
don't know if they'd have voice chat on
I oh man yeah wonder how they're gonna
handle that cuz i man like that noise
ratios I'm taking screenshots whatever
but they state they supposed to be
talking to to the people right so I mean
if you would think like yeah I think
that'd be the point I hope people aren't
stupid enough to be dumb in there or
they'll just get booted probably but
some froze
Oh dizzy be mad cuz I went to PC and I
don't play with him every day on Xbox is
um you know it is really nice to let his
nice over here
so here for me you know like that uh you
know I I'm not as regular on Xbox as he
would like that's a little bit this is
the sour grapes United gotta get back so
I will be there on Tuesday to talk to
fail yeah well I will say the emblem you
get for the new Bungie bounties for year
three is sick it's me I like that like
how that was really really nice yeah
it's like fire
that one's legit there also you may want
to tune in either way because they'll be
giving out prizes to win as a spectator
seven Destiny's shadow keep collector's
edition to award for those they are sold
out Wow they are toast yeah that will be
Tuesday September 10th 3 to 5 p.m.
Pacific adjust your time accordingly I
do love how it's no it's not gambit it's
not PvP they're not testing skill
they're doing strikes right walk it we
walk in through those strikes exactly
relax just I have the body control the
floor with me in PvP Phil placement he
play along all right now is where I'm
probably gonna hand the baton over so
first of all yeah let's get a shake
Shack's with it yeah thanks let us let
us know what we got going for the world
of personal updates cuz there's not too
many right there's not much happening
but oh yeah shake Shack's man so like I
said many of us when the kuzu experience
will change how it will change and this
is kind of what Luke Smith alluded to
and director's cut part 3 but yeah we're
gonna be getting a directors update so
when shadow keep launches your ku crews
will director will look a bit different
so here's a quick run now from the
director's cut we've removed the quick
play and competitive nodes from the
director if you look for experience like
quickly we added classic mix which is a
connection based playlist like quick
play today and classic mix will include
control clash and supremacy competitive
is replaced by 3v3 survival which now
Awards glory so competitive is now 3 B 3
survivor I know you're very happy it's
almost because I don't see count now so
that's good
oh we we've also added a survival solo
queue playlist that also Awards this is
screaming boxes like this is like they
heard your please
if you solo comp it sucks
I mean it's straight up is terrible solo
gambit solo comp
it's awful like it is and it's not
against the people who play his team's
you play as a team it's like cool you
got friends but for the people who do
play solo yeah you can't compete
generally alike unless you're just like
a god who can carry a full team which
there's a short list of those people but
it's like if you're playing with a well
organized team versus just four randoms
just the communication alone whether
it's points whether they're flankin a
super run little stuff is huge so now
this is
that's a huge deal can't wait that's you
do so now they've also added 6v6 control
as its own playlist and they state with
the potential influx of new players this
fall we want to have a playlist as
signals to new players where to start we
feel 6v6 control is the right starting
place when introducing new friends to
destiny and then they've added a weekly
66 rotator and weekly 4v4 rotator and
those rotator playlist world have modes
like clash Supremacy mayhem lockdown and
countdown will pair so there's countdown
again in that other little rotator I did
weekly rotator so basically this is some
big stuff right here now they wanted to
create some pure variety in the PvP
experience with season to season and one
way they're gonna do it is to bench map
some maps for the season while they're
out of rotation if time allows we'll
also hope to improve how they play by
treating spawn areas
ammos phones and overall structure so
they return better than before
the first four to be removed from all
playlists are I need you I need your
opinion on these four I'm looking at the
map so I have an opinion here okay yeah
dead sped cliffs alright dead cliffs is
mhm I'm looking at this one I'm trying
to I have like a map but I don't have a
picture of it so I'm trying to picture
this one in my mind dead cliffs that one
where it's like I'm gonna say it's like
it easy right I've got a list of them
dead cliffs is yeah it cdz mm-hmm and
it's that one where arm kinda stood the
heavy spawns usually by a pillar and
then um it's like a little it's hard to
describe these maps that's it's just
that brown rusted it easy yeah I'm
blanking stupidly blinking on that one
yeah yeah yeah it's always but yeah the
heavies always buy B and you got the
last chunk on the wall yes that are they
from C to B I move from C to a you got a
do that jump
you don't say I kind of gonna get the
gap and yeah kind of the back corridor
people spawn on the back a-and all right
about that one I need your opinion on it
there are folks opinions on what about
that one going away like the ones that I
think people tend to not like or the
ones that I don't like are the emissary
type levels those I think can typically
go this one I kind of like it has like
the snipe and lane from like a two B's
heavy you got that snipe down there you
got the snipe down the whole outside
walkway 4c like I don't know you
couldn't you can have multiple play
styles on this map because there are
lanes where you can snipe but there's
also like interior corridors for
shotguns
I'm usually I don't hate this one I I
may not do amazing on this map but I
like this one I'm okay with actually so
I so second is legions Gulch now I have
opinions on this if you want to pull it
up this is the one in case so this is
the big bridge you beyond its separate
side with the drill and you have a
little like shooters back and forth
mm-hmm the balance on this one is hard
yeah because basically you take a and
seems Li be alone if you're gonna be
smart about it
mm-hmm and it's it's not a balanced map
for dual flash it has its moments
because you are running around I could
see clash being more but control this
one is so unbalanced it's rough I mean
they have antsy far apart now you can
jump to it I don't know I've never been
the biggest fan of this one I know I'm
not the biggest fan the heavy internet
it's like horrible choke point in the
middle you know mm-hmm yeah yeah I'm
which I would say not what I'm okay with
actually departing I guess yeah this one
they can work on it I felt the B is just
way too far it's two separate and um you
know yeah I've never been a huge fit the
second one is a retribution pull-up
retribution
I figured the hangar the barrel and the
deck
no see I like this one I like that one
too
that's I know this is like we don't have
a lot of tight maps this is one that's
like got the loser cool yeah you got the
little loop and you got one side and the
other and the decks I'm like no I'm okay
with this one because like it's tight
corridors you got a run like you can do
a full lap around that midsection if you
need to with your super nose like that
super plane - yeah yeah so I mean this
one again completely separate from say
like solitude for example or something
like that don't see the one on my
solitude really actually don't mind that
either yeah I kind of like this one
because yeah it's one of the tighter
maps that we have so yes it is one of
those times where like you're not gonna
run anything far you do need to be mid
to close pretty much the whole time yeah
I mean yeah you can type some longer
slight curved corridors but generally
not I don't know I'm still okay with
that one when there's gonna be left
that's what I'm saying yeah here take
your maps that I like I'm like why did
he take that damn um
trials in a non map yeah that's what I'm
talking about like eight equinoxes oh I
hate that man oh I hate that from the
minute trials turning yeah hey did that
map and then it's like they kept those
long ones they kept everything trials a
denial like that the other one the other
number the other trials are the nine one
no that extra long one I'm like those
ain't out of here no anyway but um yeah
so that's it so I'm with you man I think
lesions Gulch is the only one I'm like
okay that Dan cliffs I like what you've
you should I like solitude you know I'm
just like alright really was these the
ones that people working wearing about
okay yeah solitude is the one on Mars
where you've got kin a I'm topping the
close behind the rock bees in the middle
and then season down unlike the ice
caves on the other side like that one
that's a little bigger but that's still
a map I don't mind you've got like them
nah like I'm because that that map was
fun to fight for be the fight for be on
that map sunset in that little room yeah
that's poppin I love that room yeah
everybody's
man doing all type of stuff yeah and up
on a you can like people peek out of
bees like door coming to a just get
kicked off with a snipe and the heavy on
that Center platform where it's just
open always contentious yes always that
dad that be and that heavy it popping it
is very high trackers in there yes those
maps I was kind of sad about so like I
don't know if I look through the list of
what's left but we talked about now so
I'm yeah me so like I said they said
with those bachelor move we made a pass
on all playlists from moving some maps
from playlist when they don't shine
Equinox is now only in scorched mayhem
and breakthrough and firebase every word
really what the hell is scorched does
that word cannon mode yes you know they
like that bad all you have scores canons
all the time okay really hard to hit
people with yes do you remember that yes
direct hit it's just a few Shh shoot was
away mmm
so we're gonna hit the ground yeah I'll
be missing all the time a firebase echo
is only in supremacy mayhem and
breakthrough so while we're removing a
few maps will also be introducing widows
introducing introducing the og Twilight
yeah
return those are heavy head is those -
Wow and the new map which we get a globe
glimpse of right here it's called
fragment and the description is very
accurate think dreamin city meets
infinite Boris so that's the new map
that's coming with the - so again and
getting rid of a lot that we liked but
they're adding to bonafide classics yeah
fan favorites Anna new one and then its
last point will be
elimination is also making its return to
destined to be a crucible left trials
will be testing out multiple variants of
elimination and trials rule sets and
setting to see how the mold plays with
the new weapons and abilities of Destiny
salute to the team for testing trials so
what do you think about all this and
then I'll let you grab the heavy ammo
sir man do I have an opinion about the
next topic I don't know I mean I guess
honestly they might try and just have
more rotation of maps and I guess it may
give some of them freshness if some go
out for a season some come in for a
season they kind of trade them in and
out and you don't have them all every
time I mean there may be some ones you
love and hate but like I guess new ones
in old ones out and have this kind of
rotation of things I guess I'm okay with
the rotation I'm just surprised the four
they took before they took our once I'm
generally okay with and if I had to pick
maps or move I don't know if those would
be near the top of my list I feel like
they'd be in the middle of the bottom of
Keepers I'm completely I was very
shocked that they chose those maps the
question I have for you over in rage
culture and we're in like a whole you
know Bungie did us dirty mode what say
you
I've seen this before that people at
Bungie is taking away content more
content than they'll put it in with
these maps per se well technically I'm
Matt's sake we are getting three and
losing four mm-hmm so what say you like
we should get the equal amount of maps
they are wrong for doing this we're
getting less content you know that's
that's come less content so you can know
how many pvp maps we have right now 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18
19 I don't know how many are in and out
of all the different modes but in fact
there's 19 maps and crucible for destiny
too holy crap dude like there's a lot
I'm not really probably gonna be lacking
I went through my hundred and thirty six
matches of iron banner or whatever I
made a spreadsheet of all the matches
and I was like oh where did I play I
- playing some on all some more than
others but I still saw them all
eventually but if I had only done like
five or six matches and if I don't play
that much PvP I might not even see it if
it's their chance to be like okay these
aren't being touched we're just gonna go
put these in testing I'm okay with the
idea because we're getting three we're
losing four there's other ones I would
have taken out first probably because
everyone's there there are interesting
my bigger contention is what the point
comes next but I would save for Maps is
I mean honestly you could say we're
losing maps we're also getting scorched
right which is like just a one-time
thing they goofed around with hopefully
mayhem is in the mix more frequently and
then you've got like breakthrough you've
got a couple other like couple Maps only
in certain places where like Equinox is
one scorched mayhem breakthrough
firebase that go I'd have to look up
what that one is but Equinox is one I'm
like yeah take it like yeah take that
yeah take that away no I'm watching man
I think that um this is the thing the
key point for me as to why I don't I
didn't listen to outraged culture on
this one was that um it's here's the
thing remember when we got when we
started destiny - and we were four v4i a
lot of these maps must be real they were
design for for it would not sixty-six
maps cuz then they gave us 66 they gave
us you know more power or feeling like
how are we supposed to feel but some
sinister lets up Mitch what's up oh my
god Scott but um yeah man so the whole
thing is you know if they're gonna take
them away with the intent to balance
them and fix them for sixes and do
whatever they need to do for spawn
points I'm perfectly all fine with that
I'm with you though I don't I don't like
that they chose four but yeah what does
that need beaked or not these at least
this or not these yeah but everything
else you know I'm saying the the idea of
it like hey you want to tweak it you
bring it back I have no problem with
that that is something they really never
I don't recall doing ever before and
then even nesting one where they'll take
something out and say hey we got to work
on this spawns a little so that's what's
up you know but um yeah that's what I
got on it but uh we got some heavy
things to discuss oh my god
so let's go okay so what I had joked
about last time is coming true and I'm
really worried about this heavy let's go
heavy ammo is so heavy ammo sharing is
the topic and I'm just gonna read it and
then I'm gonna let you go first
mm mm heavy ammo is shared only in the
6v6 modes and those crates have a
sparkling effect to denote this once a
player picks up the heavy ammo their
teammate have a limited amount about
seven seconds to go pick it up mmm if
the other team picked up the crate the
it will turn red you cannot pick it up
during this period of time um we each
player gets less heavy ammo from the
shared crate mm-hmm than they do from
unshared crates and 4v4 or three of you
three modes the maniman the amount of
ammo you receive from a crate as static
does not change based on how many
teammates share the crate mm-hmm go
first otherwise I'm gonna explode oh oh
I don't know I mean this is one of those
things where I have to see in practice
how I'm gonna Sara Lee feel about it all
I can do I still confuse a little
portion with the six pieces okay so back
in d1 right have you to spawn mm-hmm you
go to what the one group go to one side
the other group oh they would just fight
over the one so I don't know that is how
it used to right that's how you let it
not how it's going to that's what that's
what I want to clarify so the whole
thing in d1 I remember saying hey guys
heavies up we all go we wait for your
boy to get there he tagged you tagging
along a little late but he gets in he
gets his thing and then it's like the
Battle of the heavies for a little bit
right that's what I remember d1 so like
I said thank you for clarifying with the
way this reads is not that it's it's
literally one spot the vibe I'm getting
and we're all converging on one spot and
then the team that gets it locks out the
other team you know for that for the
thing so that's different
that's different um I don't know how I
feel I don't know how I feel it's weird
I don't understand I mean I guess it's a
it's a it's a new gang they actually
didn't have this but um you know other I
got to see how that play it just feels
what it feels people converging on one
spot battle for the heavy you know it
could snowball it could snowball it
could the only thing I'm thinking about
is like yo it could snowball
once those guys got it it kind of done
for a bit now they are saying it's less
heavy you know then it would be if he
was an individual unshared crate and for
me taking Robin lunch her for example
I'm just gonna jump in there we go they
don't ever example one person can pull
it right now and get a max of 2 mm or
what truth gets 3 technically yeah even
if say six people are there and say they
all have rockets that still six Rockets
between them it's more than we've ever
had and you want to talk about waiting
the match to one side for a really long
period of time that match just gots one
horribly out of balance it's not like
both teams get heavy they smash in the
middle and one person like I would do
hang in the back with my machine gun and
then I'll run in later and be the guy
with the machine gun who's still got
heavy and be like I'll be a little
annoying for a bit but there was chaos
on both sides for a little while mm-hmm
oh that's cute you all have sniper
rifles and scouts and hand cannons we
all have six or at we at six of us have
a rocket launcher right now what are you
gonna do you're all screwed
hmm even if they all got like 15 bullets
a machine gun ammo that's still two
kills each probably that's my main issue
is it's you take fighting over heavy
ammo and one person gets 38 bullets of
heavy and they still tend to like kill
you twice now you have an entire team
potentially that can pick it up and
swing it even more
I feel where you're going but here's the
thing this he Scott is about to say what
I was about to say which is part of the
strategy back in the day was you go over
there which is stupor so if they was
over there camping ready that team's
ready to take you coming in with the
super and then swing the pendulum you
know saying but I hear what you say
you're not wrong if a team six people
get heavy
your talk you're about to get rolled out
to build it thanks
you better get roped out so that part is
a little spooky
I have to admit I give you that it
sounds crazy to me that that sparks
happening there is some strategy though
there is some [ __ ] if you say if you
super up like you say Nova over there
Titan hammer over there go ahead touch
it if you want and will you snipe I set
up you could still counter a little you
can still kind of look but it I agree
it's gonna be tight okay so say one
person picks it up they have seven
seconds to get it you sniper can't get
three or four people to pass through and
pick up their block on the way to let go
kill people you got your other five you
got your other five you do but like I'm
just saying like there's typically the
map met with the way the map is going if
they're typically there it's not like
you're gonna spawn near them if they
just wiped you guys out before heavy
they use their super y'all are on the
other side of the map but they just load
it up on heavy good luck I think this is
gonna be I think this is gonna be awful
you could be right oh this is gonna be
awful you could be very right I want to
see how the place all I think about is
this this is my experience
alright when I play every time I get
over to the heavy there is literally
three dudes setting up tents said they
are waiting for me the tie I know that's
how it is but I'm also just saying like
there's gonna be the point where that's
still gonna happen one or two people may
get it they might have a little less
ammo the snipe still may pick them off
some heavy bricks may drop who knows but
in the moment or one team does it right
or one team is wrecking it's not gonna
you were not gonna get that balanced
moment back if a team is owning that
match and wrecking you and they're
chaining supers right which is gonna be
a little harder we'll get to that but
still they still are running the table
that met there that becomes an even
farther unbalanced match mmm there's no
way to return there's no way for both
you to be like all right split off for
your heavy cool all right we got it one
guy tried to come okay a snipe tamales
thinking about doing something alright
everybody use your heavy all right now
chaos will ensue
oh we survived a little better I've got
some machine gun hey we can try and kind
of hold things a little bit here that is
never gonna happen if one team starts
wrecking it and holding it I have a
feeling this is gonna be bad no I have
you know what about the counter-argument
that says well that's the better team
like that dad strategize to to converge
on that spot and it's doing a better job
of protecting NASA mercy either going to
affect quicker I was like mercy just has
to be faster if it likes I'm just saying
like this is gonna swing the balance of
a match potentially that like hey we're
down by like 20 points but we're working
on coming back okay somebody just did a
super and killed like four of us crap
and heavy spawned [ __ ] the whole team
has heavy almost like it's now you're
done so I was like I have a feeling this
is not gonna go well well what what is
it effective you getting smacked but
you're good at controlling happy and
that lets say that team is better how
because what you just said you're
getting smacked about your control
you're not you're not getting smacked
too controlling anything in what's a
Matta generally I'm being extreme what
I'm saying is let's just say you're
being outplayed on one on one gunfights
with another team the other team is 2p a
little better than your team in
one-on-one gunfights right so you're
constantly down but when that heavy
comes then you could kind of swing it
because your guys did a better job
strategizing and positioning to control
that heavy or the other kind of argument
is what again I with you I'm just trying
to be I'm doing devil's advocate
actually it's funny that I'm doing this
cuz I'm actually a nephew so um the
other argument is what if people say yo
let them rock we super up and then we
take it from no because you know what
you kill they go out they're gonna poop
heavy that's the work feel so you got
that too it's I wanted to give it a shot
that's what I'm saying yeah III I think
I saw this last week and I saw this and
I was just like damn
[Music]
I mean for me yeah it was like I guess
we'll just have to see an action because
they're better have been some testing
behind this but mm-hmm I have a feel
it's the matches that already feel out
of balance are gonna feel that much
worse because if you're already getting
stomped and all of a sudden there and
tired like you seen six people just
picked up heavy and they're not on your
team you just like quit look all tough
for shutting down to the night you turn
throw the Xbox across the room doesn't
matter like it that matches done but
then they saying which we're about to
read is that this is about to get us
into that skilled players play a ranking
skill thing that we gonna touch you on
next so maybe that's what that's about
everybody trying to separate the men
from the boys and put you in your rail
rank so you're not a ring it but we'll
get to that but um yeah mess oh yeah
that's heavy its controversial we shall
move on rank systems update streaks and
flaws this one is interesting for me
Laurie Valley are you gonna yeah I got
it glory and glory valor and infamy
streaks have been made more resilient
instead of resetting your streak losses
will now reduce your valor and infamy
streaks by one and your glory Street by
two you can still lose glory but if your
rank is at or below fable you can't lose
glory if doing so would drop you below
that rank each rank through fabled act
as a floor for glory so you are a man of
you're a man you're a man that uh went
through the hard grind if you lost glory
you would go down right you know how you
feel they are casual izing your great
mountain top sisters boy so essentially
when you go up into yeah yo I'm like as
you're going like guardian won't go home
to get anyone brave hey there if you
lose you stay those with that big right
typically I mean especially if they're
going like brave will and brave two
brave three if you can go all the way up
to like brave and then all the way back
down to them brave before you like drop
The Guardian like you gets 100 your
guardian like cool then you know like
going up and brave then if you get too
brave to and you hold it mm-hmm I think
I'd like to break point of fabled cuz up
to 2100 even solo queueing you'd
eventually probably bounce there cuz I
was like working my way up and then I
ran into that guy and he helped me the
rest of the way mm-hmm I think it's
gonna ease the journey up to there mm
but then I think they the pinnacle stuff
like I think they need to do something
above that for those who want to go
above the 2,100 glory right so making a
harder part more you got to give me a
reason to go above fabled because like
if you're I can't go below like you
could just barely creep over languages
bill you guys you got I got brave too
and then you lose like four times you're
like mmm thank God I got the brave too
okay okay now we're like back on ok now
we're doing good again
and I think it's gonna be more of a
sight but I think when you get to fable
be like hey those those training wheels
take them off now you go up you go down
where you that's where you're at late I
rank up to fabled a lot of people who
try and comp
mm-hmm eventually might head that
direction I mean some have big swings
down and up and it's definitely gonna be
a thing where like yeah you have your
big swing I do too like I went up and
then lost like I'm lost we go ahead and
shut this down this is not happening
tonight it's like there are times where
you do that and that mate that honestly
the floors may be like hey I can only go
solo even if I dropped a couple matches
right it's not gonna be as bad a make I
might keep playing well I think this is
gonna be a better thing for the playlist
mmm only there because this is a
playlist decision I think it's better
for the playlist so the people at the
lower levels have it like less worried
of like hey I got mm hey I played eight
matches and I'm down to like 200 now yep
and I was just going yeah it's the mom
be honest like it was demoralizing to me
and I had to take a step back for a
while but I listen I understand both
sides here right the competitive
hardcore guy like a sinister who was
booing
you know he's gonna say look get good
you don't I mean he's gonna say get good
if you losing you lose your rank that is
what the true ranking system represents
and I understand that argument I am the
problem for Bungie is that no one's
really play this map is this playlist'
anymore yeah because you got the extreme
hardcore that will get there the super
try hards or super sweats that will get
there that's a very small percentage
they have to have the numbers on
engagement in comp it has to be terrible
because I know for a fact I'm sitting in
orbit waiting oh and I see a lot of
other people bro I see the same people
so this has to be a way that this is
their balance I said okay you know what
the casual guy is not sticking around
he's getting ZZ you may get a two shriek
he gets stomped he's all the way back
down the brave one or whatever it is and
he's out for the night he's never
stepping back in calm they want people
to get in calm you give them that floor
so if they do win they get it they take
their streaks away right
they take strict potential away about
one by one but oh my god spot this guy
here's how it is basically what is this
about five to seven ranks you know
circle ranks and then basically what
happens is when you fill up your circle
with wins and experience you move to the
next rank so what how it used to work is
as you go up in rank right if you lose
it would take away your streaks may see
as you go up a run you go up on a streak
you get more experience each with more
experience with each win when you lose
now they take away that a streak and
then if you continue to lose you can
actually drop rank that's what pretty
much how glory ranking will work the new
way what they're saying is if you
basically this fabled as I say fabled is
kind of like that upper tier too close
to the top yep they see every level you
gain up until fabled if you make it to
that level if you lose you will not go
but believe that level so it's almost
like you'll have a constant chance to
keep getting to fabled you know the
matter no matter how many the loss
eventually you'll get there once you
start winning you know saying but once
you hit fabled now whatever the next
ranks are mythic and all that other
stuff legend or whatever it is above
fable if you make mythic and then start
losing you can go all the way back down
to fable if that's how the new system
works so again
me personally I think it's a it's a cool
middle ground to help the casual guys
but still I agree with Yui they're gonna
have to now have something above fabled
to give the hardcore guys that grind
grind all whether it was a dabbed or
whether it was you know what was the
equivalent for Lunas how what was it it
was it was it was this were not
forgotten not forgotten yes yes maybe
they end yeah
maybe they'll do a better version maybe
they'll trials it out and give me that
kind of thing so you know you know oh my
god is days with goodbye account
recovery people that honestly is like I
think real office and then also the
skill base they can talk about later and
ice that'll be kind of an interesting
thing because even as to cross was
talking about that I mean if you look up
I pulled up the ranks
so like Guardian one two and three brave
one two and three and heroic one two and
three that's mostly what we're talking
about right Guardian one takes 40 points
of the next rank Guardian to 70 and
Guardian 390 then brave one 170 to 95
and 385 like each rank takes more so to
go from brave to to brave three is gonna
take you'll have a bigger swing in there
and then heroic one two and three is 210
365 and 475
so I mean depending on which one you're
in you can't have further to follow the
closer you get to fabled where it's
still gonna be a challenge but you're
not gonna go from 2099 go on a crap
streak and go home and go to bed at like
500 yeah and be and be demoralized that
literally will be the fact the deciding
factor that make you stop playing and if
you look at it the other point I want to
make is that the latest pinnacle weapon
that they introduced a sniper to me
showed me this was the direction they
were gonna go in because if you looked
at that weapon it was you kind of kept
progress right what was it what's this
lever revoke her right that's the only
pinnacle weapon they kind of did that
with you you could still steady get it
done you're just total points good
better otherwise you couldn't lose any
points right that's the thing so I think
is a good change I think it's a good
change for the the health of the
playlist and overall
you need people in there so I'm with it
as long as you give the hardcore some
bragging right weapon or variant that
represents that legend only they could
get to so they can feel like you I don't
want to be on the same level as these
other dudes I put in that work you know
yeah I mean I think that would be the
way to make it keep more people in the
playlist in the lower levels where they
want more people and then where it gets
ultra sweaty they need a reason for it
to get to be sweaty and that's I think
everything in this game needs to have
something behind there or why am I gonna
go run legend nightmare hunt it is just
a piece of armor now the stats will be
there but again it's like giving rewards
for ultra difficult things needs to be
there otherwise what's the point right
so let's you get up competitive
matchmaking updates all right skill and
glory destiny has always tracked players
behind the scenes taking into account
things like kills damage dealt and so
forth these factor into a player's skill
rating now they said in season eight
we've mapped the skill ratings to glory
ranks so lowest into the scale mapping
to Guardian 1 the highest into legend
most players are somewhere in between
those extremes yep
as you play in the survival playlist
which is just the only place to get
glory going forward the glory system
will accelerate you to the rank that
corresponds to your skill rating if your
current rank is below where your skill
rating should be you'll earn extra glory
based on the criteria above so you can
get to your expect to drink faster and
lose less glory so you don't fall
farther away once you read your quote
expected a ranked glory gains and losses
will kind of normalize mm-hmm so if
you're like going in you know getting
you know 20 kills a match or something
at low levels you're gonna kind of kind
of scoot up to that you know min to rank
where you're supposed to be faster but
then if you get around like hey you hit
fabled you get to live here now if
you're going above that you're not gonna
fly up as fast you're gonna be at that
normalized leveling pretty standard
stuff but also if you go into a match
and you're you know you plate you're
doing okay at a low level but then you
go against like a recovery team for some
reason and you're like okay I'm in like
guardian
to here and I just got absolutely
stomped you're not gonna lose as much
either so that's smart enough to do what
it says that all sounds really good
actually yeah meanwhile your skill
rating is continually adjusting based on
your performance shifting the system's
understanding of your expected rank and
causing the glory system and respond by
pulling you toward that rank the results
should be over time your glory rink will
become an accurate reflection of your
skill it also mean the teammates of
different skill will experience
different glory adjustments from the
same survival match hmm interesting
stuff here what do you think what do you
think yeah I kind of like it because um
I think ultimately this is gonna push
them closer to the the balance as far as
matchmaking that they want it's never
gonna be perfect let's just be clear
right it's never gonna be perfect but
the thing about it is that at least if
you get to sweat in their sweaty group
they with a red yeah let them be what
they're supposed to be and let the rest
be what they suppose like everyone will
be a little bit more even to again we
have we've heard things like this from
you know I mean not to this extent we've
heard you know things about them trying
to improve from the skill skill base and
stuff like that you know
this is probably the most transparent
they've been in reference to this yep
and I like what I'm hearing you know I'm
saying because again if I'm starting now
and I'm playing you know what my you
know with someone who is you know super
sweat tear you know this is the guy and
we're ranking up he should rank up
faster because based on what his skill
is if they factor in KD if they're fat
whatever their fact on it if he's a
beast he should not be on the playground
with me beaten up little kids everyday
yep
get him up there and let him beast out
eventually to where he needs to be me
it'll be a gradual progression do
whatever because they're but let me play
with the guys who are on my level so at
least I feel like I'm somewhat I don't
fit in out here but it's demoralizing
and get then get destroyed by team sweat
so
that's where I'm at with it again sounds
great in theory I hope this all works
right you know theoretically cool but
you'll have to see I mean even sinister
said in Chinese like smart matching
smart matchmaking will never happen
and honestly we won't know until we get
to see if I go in this and comp and like
I'm a little you know a little more
forgiveness with the floors and you know
hopefully fifty account recoveries
aren't happening the same time I play
that's the hardest part as those
honestly cuz I mean as I've played up
whether I bumped into people and had
help on it whatever it is the people
playing at that level typically are not
the ones actually just at that level
because some people just don't want to
but they want the then what the reward
so they'll find some way to get it and
that's where that's where the issues
come in that's all right absolutely and
what in a theory for a normal group of
people the good ones should be up top
shadow keep has a few sandbox changes to
abilities mini
be quick if you look at like the scroll
bar on the side of my page I'm like a
third down the page right now if you
guys are wondering if this was I think
this update is as long of a page of
scrolling text as all three of Luke's
things probably put together I mean yeah
this is definitely the largest writing
my autograph like yeah I'm gonna have to
be selective and what I talked about
because there's a thousand things in
here and they're all significant they
like oh they're pretty good chunk so
let's get to it
first night soccer where the Pathfinder
this is the bottom tree they kind of
tease it about with regards to the
armored stream when they did their
strike yes they don't wanna lead farther
into the fantasy of a speedy disruptor
Pathfinder need to find tools to scout
the battlefield and ways to engage with
gameplay more often so vanish smoke bomb
grants invisibility to allies gives one
stacked of heart of the pack newly
revamped to all allies hit now this is
where like the stats may be different
grants plus 34 to armor recovery and
agility which I guess that would be
maybe resilience
is where that would go and gives max
reload speed and handling max of three
stat gives a weapon reload speed and
handling max three stacks increase
invisibility duration by a second
provision killing tethered enemies
creates super orbs and increases agility
armed and recovery for allies new perk
old perk benefits moved to be part of
Mobius quiver damaging enemies with your
grenade reduces the cooldown of your
smoke bomb 6% per tick making making
allies invisible gives you grenade
energy so working on getting your
grenade back more frequently and then
mobium quiz Mobius quiver fires multiple
fire super multiple times and deals
massive damage to tethered targets mmm
added to added the old provision perk to
naturally be part of Mobius quiver
killing tethered enemies create super
orbs and grant stacks of heart lapak for
allies extended the range of heart of
the pack from 20 to 30 meters mmm so
it's like a big support grenade tether
build mmm everything very big so I think
well it's support with the with the with
the whole making making your allies
invisible yeah invisible and extra armor
and reload speed all those things are
gonna be pretty big so yeah yeah that
invisibility throw helping people out in
the pinch using that as recovery getting
them out of tough spot tethering enemies
making more orbs having farther range on
a heart of the pack I mean this is
they're changed in the way some of these
feel they want to really help some of
these supers to be viable and I think
this is a long time in the making which
is nice mmm-hmm shadow shots super low
and bottom damage increased from 150 to
250 one-shot kill in PvP hmm improve
tether accuracy near obstacles
suppresses on hit is more consistent
whoa so this is big this big this makes
tether viable again yeah that's not like
I don't know what sinister was
complaining about what we talking before
they show he's a bit he's a bit easy
hunter main and he was you know I I'm
like did you not read these like this
damaging
one-shot kill that's what hunters been
one a one-shot kill
I'm PvP with it and then I said improve
tether accuracy suppress on hit he's
wrestled hit the big one like if you get
hit you of that delay were you eating it
out of crab like nah shut him down
that's the whole point of this super
it's the shuttle down so no that's yeah
that's huge that's gonna be big big time
so yeah that's that's probably the
biggest ones is just tethers actually
gonna be one shot kills people even
impacts said they were feeling that but
also just the bottom trees they talked
about before much more viable in a lot
of places Sentinel code of the protector
top tree mmm-hmm all right this path is
the main support role for Titans and
focuses heavily on melee while staying
near allies we want to focus more on
heavily buffing allies so the players
can take care can't care about timing of
their buff usage so defensive strike
male ability that creates an over shield
for nearby allies all kills while the
over shield is active grant melee energy
for the player with the shield rallying
force melee kills heal nearby allies if
you're up there like punching all the
guys running up to you then you're doing
a good thing for your team heal bow
phallus from heal buff from 10 health
and 10 shield to 10 health and 20 shield
which still seems small but you know
he'll see you yep Ward of done yes
increase ward health verse supers most
supers will require the whole thing to
be dumped onto the ward destroy it but
will usually not kill the player inside
mmm so now like if somebody wants to
break a bubble they got a dump of super
to break your super right which is no
fair
Ward's grants weapons of light buff when
passing through it
35% weapon damage for 15 seconds that's
a long time you passed through at once
work on it for a while I don't know how
long it last passed through it that one
more time take it with you bro
that's a turnstile right there just
going in now getting that 35 as being
what you're gonna have to
now passing through coming back out made
everybody just line up and circle
through all right I'm firing him firing
reloading and getting my buff alright
fire and fire and find reloading you're
getting my buff justice or moon grants
additional super orbs that's fine but
the big one is like weapons of light we
knew it was coming back
35% buff for 15 seconds is large I mean
this is definitely gonna be a viable
super now in certain situations mainly a
lot of PvE fights I mean can you imagine
even just ward of it on on a control
point that's what I'm saying
think about that people just camping
them and just all you gotta do is pass
through you got the bubble and then
somebody out there is 35% extra damage
you're gonna lose that fight if you're
both like similarly accurate you will
lose
you're gonna lose 5% as large a sit loco
to the aggressor bottom shield best
shoulder charge of the disorients nearby
enemies now suppresses the target hit
and any enemy within 2 meters but they
say but they basically have to be
standing right next to him but if you
knew shield bash two people close the
other person's gonna have a harder time
killing you which is good mm-hmm I'll
let you talk about your warlock action
yes sir void walking us a bottom tree
which has not really been using as much
but vortex Nova bomb leaves behind a dam
Gao a cold initial explosion damage
increased by 15% then also the lingering
damage is increased by since that's new
no that's the name that what it is is
basically rule from Nova bomb oh no
above yeah I was thinking Nova warp warp
yeah so you throw that bad boy down then
it still has the effect and it'll stay
there shout out to par 5 warlocks and
house you already know yeah that's a big
deal but we'll get into the next one
dawn blade a to meant of grace well of
radiance alternate super that creates a
healing buffing feel for allies and then
as now it's gonna grant an additional
orb so actually another one that's
adding another and then Auto generated
orbs now grant the same amount of super
energy as regular super orbs previously
the orbs gave less super energy on the
power
master so well yeah this is interesting
and I say I think they're trying to make
you know say right quickly definitely
trying to make bottom tree more sexy as
far as an oval ball because everybody's
taking top because of Cataclysm because
it would split and those little joints
would track you and I mean so but I
think this could be significant because
they crease it's a basic a double buff
increasing the damage of it initially
and the lingering damage so you some
carpet effect with it as well it's gonna
be interesting man you know a to man of
grace with the arm which called is just
as cool I guess
I'm only thing I was disappointing you
know dawn blade top tree needs love and
I'm shocked that nothing got blessed
with top tree because top tree they want
you to kind of stay in the air lot and I
think I only have like one exotic that's
really a top tree exotic and that
doesn't really do anything you know from
damage or whatever I think they still
have to do something for for top tree
dorm blade and now that's what I was
hoping for and I didn't get that I was
not surprised by that part but in my
present yeah boy definitely bottom tree
void Jeff really needs something it's
not being chosen all right now used to
be a very viable bill okay
no no I was gonna say nerfs way of the
trapper top tree Nightstalker
fire's shadow shot fires an arrow that
damages enemies and debuffs enemies
nearby damage sharing for Night Stalker
player specifically reduced from 100 to
50 percent now all allied players have
50% damage sharing on tether so is that
like flipped where you don't do as much
but everybody else can yes that would it
feels like yeah they're making it the
way to trap us to support the support
joint so they're inducing the player but
all your allies have 50% damage on that
tell us Sharon is nerf but that's I mean
it's just spreading the love more than
anything
again this is the one since it was
freaking out they reduced it about
whatever but if you're tethering and
you're giving your whole team 50% more
damage as a team that's a big deal seems
like it's okay unless it was like a
hundred percent for everybody and now
everybody's reduced but if not everybody
else got that got to share in it then I
feel like that's what it should have
been the whole time honestly yes I agree
to me functionality-wise feeling you
should be it away of the race
flawless execution headshot kills while
cramped green invisibility and true side
truesight now last three seconds instead
of nine thank you yes kidding me I've
seen truesight and like cool guys videos
in other people's videos that is so
busted yeah yeah yeah true sights like
I'm sorry there's more max not really
cool mmm-hmm shattering strike after
performing a flawless execution your
melee attacks have a longer lunge range
and weaken enemies and they said this
got tied in with flawless execution
they're gonna mix a little like issue
with it where this lasts longer but then
the true side doesn't last as long so
those were tied together hold on we got
some contention hunters are when it's
saying for Daniel for King is sinister
they saying with the shadow shot that
because it used to do everyone had a
hundred percent damage you know I'm
saying it's nerve right so as far as the
allied players as well so so everybody's
getting less yeah so that that's their
point contain a like nope it's still
nerve we used to do a hundred percent
and allies used to do a hundred percent
now we're doing for the percent so they
paste wait wait yeah with that I mean
that's this is it deserved I don't think
so okay I mean now damage sharing for
the Night Stalker players specifically
reduced from 50 to 100 now all Li
players have 50% sharing on tether
I guess if everybody's down to 50%
damage sharing maybe they just don't
want I mean they're going towards this
just trying not to nerf everything
faster right
I guess they felt tether was too strong
I guess I guess my mentality is if
someone if a hunter initiates the tether
right
and are we look first of all we're
looking at this from from a PvP
specifically we look at that I'm going
PvE alright so if I'm not really so
worried about right so what look that
has a PvE yes this is a nerf this is a
hard nerfing sense that yeah we used to
do hundred percent damage now we're
doing fifty percent damage on you know
said top targets I get that but the
other thing too that we have to keep in
mind is that with this whole I'm not I'm
not saying it's right but the vibe the
vibe we're getting is the same way when
we were using the exotics that was
generating all orbs and we were super
chaining all that other stuff to me it
seems like they're trying to control
that aspect of not letting this get out
of hand based on whatever they got
planned cuz it was the same thing with
uh I was like damn why they nerfed
diorama Cara you know Phoenix protocol
we got killed on that so like those
exotics in conjunction with that super
now made it not as powerful anymore so
there it seems to me they are scared of
y'all because of y'all hundred percent
with what they got playing going on with
that's just the vibe that's how it to me
how Bungie seems to work and we've been
sharing is one thing you think about too
is like I know if you think about hey
tether the boss or whatever we used to
do like even in d1 it wasn't as never
much about sharing the damage I mean
yeah this is a nerf and sharing damage
but you're still the little guy is that
quick if you're still trying to like
debuff the boss that's right which is
what we gonna get to that point
to me this is slowing them down from
melting bosses like the vibe that seem
to be consistent is they don't want
false melting
they don't want dudes throwing the
tether doing a joint they don't want to
do sitting in one spot doing what they
do that's the vibe I'm hearing all that
comes right here okay let's instead
reloading in the beginning Luna factions
and Bradley barricade did exist they
were clunky to use they had they still
had dramatic impact on gameplay but
eventually they decided their effects
became easier to handle so then they
tweaked I mean rally barricade you
didn't have to crouch behind it to get
your real oh they just made
standing behind it something they've
changed things up luna factions working
with well of Radiance which was
introduced later on that broke the damn
game mm-hmm
so the big changes here tighten but
rally barricade and well of Radiance
warlock rift luna faction boots are
gonna be the same thing the ability now
provides a large increase to reload
speed for the duration of the effect
this ability no longer automatically
reloads your weapon from reserves both
of more anyway though the hunters if you
feel like you got nerfed trust me we
just can't ours this is us all the way
you watch I got it whoo this is
literally everyone's flow everyone from
every raid oh yeah
put out the rally barricade you're gonna
have to learn how to fight running again
don't let the little factions and this
is everybody getting hit with this oh
you're gonna fight Riven for real yeah
spike grenade bingo work I mean you can
still put out damage just depends on how
quick you can reload you know I guess I
know people are still gonna test Riven
though I mean people melt ribbon fast so
depending on if it's late I mean I'm
trying to think what's a really fast
reload like if it's like an outlaw
reload it's gonna be pretty quick still
it's just not like Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam
Bam Bam so I mean there's gonna be a
breath in there they're trying at some
reload mccann they try to put that
breath in it and the biggest thing is
something like this probably affects
mountain-top more than anything else yes
cuz mountain top is a single shot breach
and if you can just dump 15 shots of
mountaintop yeah that's that's broken
like at least you boom it don't it could
be faster but you can't I mean it lowers
the DPS of that thing drastically swarm
of the Ravens the drum load the heavies
like prospector and swarm you're still
gonna get six or seven out of those get
a quick reload six or seven you're still
gonna be able to do a good chunk with
your heavies this is their this is
actually probably the smartest way they
can take mountaintop out of being busted
yeah you can shoot it here wipe out this
quick enemy shoot it into you know a
major knock him out real quick but
you're not just gonna unload mountaintop
after you unloaded your swarm of the
Raven
standing still inviting bosses we knew
it was going away it was coming they
hinted at this
Luke was one of the first things he said
you'd understand when one of those
directors joy saw this this is no
surprise I will say this though here's
my only issue and I said it my article
got the article up right now check it
out Lord gave me that net put it in
there for y'all my issue is this when
it's abilities I get it right
you know it's an ability it's a well
it's a rally barricade I get that my
issue comes down to arm as far as the
whole exotic when you have exotics that
are specific just to do one thing as far
as but what would uh what Luna factions
the whole purpose of Luna faction is
literally just so your allies can not
have to reload a poll from research
right now they take this away all I'm
saying
let's give stuff like this stuff like
the finish protocol stuff some other
passive thing now that it can do because
it really is kind of useless now I mean
because less is real what I mean that's
one thing not needs to happen to a lot
of armor though it's like any things
that don't have great functions or
unuseful like you have the data who's
using half of these damn exotics maybe
on Sol never been reworked how is the
entire a on set never been like alright
this is a failed experiment people have
it out there can we make this something
that's what I'm saying like they've got
listen we know they got a lot on my
plate I'm not gonna be respectful but
when it comes to non-functional exactly
you've got the usage rates ain't nobody
running around with these joints they're
not running around with them this
unfortunately skull is now this now Luna
faction is this there's no knee if I
have the well you know why would I you
put it this way you don't say I'm good
Tasi part I shot at a see literally Luna
faction has become a fitting a Spanish
in a way is like okay you know you
reload a lot
fast like what what's gonna
differentiate the the lula faction boots
and the Ophidian aspects joint which
kind of now yeah what is it you know do
the same thing they've got to now give
it passive secondary functionality on
something else so that you can use it
for something else that's pretty much
all out saying yeah that's like they are
quick about making me like okay we're
gonna change the way this works okay
well if it's useless just like it just
starts crossing more exotics off the
list of bugs and they wonder why we
always get steered into these places
because we don't have it six viable
other options there's still just one
option is gonna be there they're afraid
to like bring other things too close to
other like well this is this is too
powerful let's bring it out okay this is
where we're at is nothing else is on
this level
really mmm-hmm well crap I agree so it's
a balancing of those used and unused you
know there's data I mean I get there's
like ones that have certain uses but I
mean how often are some of those oddball
things really used exactly there's tons
of exact again and they and it start of
d2 they started off strong we weren't
working a lot of them if you remember
remember they like hey we taking these
three we're gonna give them back to you
now they do this right they got to get
back in pocket with that that's all yeah
super energy regeneration probably
almost more pvp than the other mm-hm
these changes will reduce to speed which
players are able to earn this super
which supports difficulty and reduces
the current ability to trivialize
certain content through excessively
chaining supers systematically we want
to reduce based sources of soup on a
large macro scale without diminishing
the feeling that your actions are you
are gaining you are worthwhile energy
boost by reducing the speed at which you
gain super we can make mods and perks
feel more worthwhile we still want it to
feel like you could make meaningful
progress not only do normal play by my
oven ting super energy through tea
burke-class choices
and skillful play then we got the whole
breakdown with energy granted by super
oil which basically percent reduction
won our Superman at 50% master work orbs
have been hit to fifty percent reduction
down at 2.5% kills in general 25%
reduction and any breakdowns all those
percentages down per enemy and all that
stuff
assists 25% reductions so uh yeah real
quick on this II arm where you at look
at the super reduction main um I think
it's gonna be better for PDP yeah so
people don't chain as much or if one
team goes on that super tear they don't
just all this haven't fill each other
supers and it's just this constant
progression or you get a third into a
match and everybody's just going super
crazy the whole time yeah snowball like
the kills seem like binary reductions so
you get a little bit a little bit less I
mean it's obviously you look at the
numbers they're pretty small in the
first vice that you get so I mean
they're gonna steer you to or it's more
a higher intellect build if you want
supers right that's I think where
they're gonna want to steer you towards
to make that more viable right I'm legit
I won't really know how this feels good
until we actually see it in action
because I mean in destiny too we had
crap weapons and really slow supers oh
yeah I was your one point everything was
like bro slow supers and slow ability to
the point that they had to make exotics
to increase super recharge rates and
stuff like that yeah remember that so
mmm I know
so I mean you see super orbs being 50%
less masterwork orbs being 50% less I
mean yeah you can stack them a lot
sometimes I've seen people be pretty
crazy at a point I won't know until I
play it really and I guess we'll just
have to see I'm in the supers one of
those that in PvE I wish this was almost
like PvP only more because in PvP when
it gets out of control just kind of like
the heavy have when it gets out of
control
it gets really out of control and
they're stacking and chaining people
just run on behind people at supers be
like alright who's the next
the Train all right you can leave
instead we're gonna follow behind you
but in PvE you've got simply so much
going on as pure chaos like chaining
supers and stuff there's a strategy to
doing it in PvE that I feel like is no
detriment to you right so I guess I
don't know I'll have to see how it feels
but if it's too much in PvE I think
that's where I'll have my issue PvP it's
fine cuz it brings more skill back into
it and gunplay and stuff like that as
opposed to just supers and abilities and
Nova's and throwing hammers and whatever
else you're gonna do that I'm okay
because that brings more skill into it
but in PvE it is still space magic and I
want to have some fun I think that's my
balance between him we got damage
multipliers we knew this was coming
mm-hm the biggest way to sum this up
you're gonna have one buff and one
debuff kind of said that last week when
we were talking about some of the
artifact stuff you can't have well of
radiance and weapons of light on that at
the same time and you can't go to avoid
tractor cannon with it and hammer strike
and a tether
now the debuff typically would only do
one but your buffs
probably seemed a little broken so now
we're kind of at the point where they're
fixing that one on one side and one on
the other
they've got frontal assault bonus
damages 20% was 25 Sun warrior bonus
damages now 20 was 25 well of radiance
is now 25 was 35 weapons light is now 35
was 25mm so weapons of light is stronger
well as weaker but you can stand and
well and you don't have to move so in
the balance those are gonna be pretty
similar debuffs shadow shot is now less
incoming damage this effect no longer
excludes power weapons though for shadow
shots and that is that is a good fix
tractor cannon I did not know this by
the way you might have got is this
always been there
yeah well that this was been edited
because when tractor can it was just
void it was just void this now says for
all elements the
changing it again yeah changing it once
again this is know what let wouldn't
look when it first came out I recall you
could track the cannon in any element
that was affected I mean any element
that you used after you buff the I mean
you debuff with with the tractor would
get the damage multiplier then they
nerfed it and said okay it gotta be void
and it could be void only but then we're
gonna reduce the percentage of how much
you're gonna be gonna let you deal off
now they're going back to all you know
say it looks like say and annum it's
almost less but it's less yeah so that's
the new backer candidates now just like
not avoid thing it's just how does a
debuff debuff but less across-the-board
debuff a hammer strike is down to 30%
duration increase though from 6 to 10 so
that's like that's a trade it's a trade
I mean you give up well you give up 40%
you get probably about 40% in time so I
mean it's a you got to survive longer
you can't just dump it quicker right
just a lot of their theme shattering
striking identical same thing yes but
yeah they're changing the buffs reduce
super damage resistance this is your um
as far as I got to read and so I'm gonna
give you this one yeah yeah so basically
oh yes its launch day basically slowly
introduce buffs to supers they don't
want people to run around mindless so
basically what they're saying is not
long ago we experimented with spectral
blades by lowering the damage resistance
substantially these changes were
generally well received and improved the
experience for the Supra for both the
person running it and the person who was
running from it in PvE
players shouldn't feel they're super
makes them invulnerable and casting one
should call for situational strategic
thinking in PvP players need to feel
that they can challenge a super and that
would skillful play there's a chance
they can beat it so super damage
resistance removed from masterwork armor
everyone thought everybody did master
all five of you here is stupid damage
resistance lowered by a category C below
so low
54% down to 49% do our Nova war Thunder
crash blaze barrage Nova bomb and well
of Radiance so those goes down 45449
medium will be from 56 to 51 hammer of
Sol and they break supers and the high
group will be the fist of havoc birdie
mob same to new shoe arc staff alright
lightning and shadow shot those go down
from 60% till 53% and the others
unchanged will be spectral blade staying
the same golden gun and chaos reach so
II super damage resistance way you act
with this well I mean they're they're
all basically 50% now 54 down to 49 56
down to 51 50 or 60 down to 53 they're
all basic around 50 I mean the easier
supers are to kill the better
mm-hm I mean yeah being killed by
roaming supers forever sucks but II they
say we want they want to make us feel
powerful at the beginning of the d2 and
now they're taking away my power fancy
what about that
this is PvP right yeah I was like in PvP
players need to feel like they can
challenge a super that's the biggest
thing about this entire sentence PvP
players shouldn't feel like they're
super makes them more vulnerable and
casting one should call for situational
strategy rules strategic thinking I
would have run my super on loop and get
you when you spawn again yeah he'll know
that know if I could kill by the Hawaii
and then see you spawn and kill you
again with my roaming super this is
unfair bungeed nerf nerf nerf language
warning incoming cover your ears that's
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah it's like I think everybody is so
tired of is that the same oh my god
that's the same damn tight and it's
typically tightens in spectral blades
and dawn blades because you guys can fly
on the free and map you're the same -
cuz you last long like even super we're
killing stuff makes it extend weak as
hell you need to be weeks off facts you
gotta play it smart and if you're
invisible like a hunter man you need to
be weak Titans running around at least
you gotta see us coming dawn blades you
guys fly around your heart as hell they
hit but dude in a fast if you're
warlocks you look she she shooting every
other souls like at least those Titans
kind of have to run places mm-hmm I'm
fine with it um yeah and this is not me
excuse it's just again the the consensus
is when someone here you hear a super
you run it's never an option to
challenge you're going to lose so now yo
you've got a shop if you're cut like
basically you just can't be reckless if
you're losing your super you still gonna
get killed you just can't be reckless
you know coming down a block a mile away
hey I'm here I'm coming to get you
you know saying you could get whit now
now you could get that way you could
gets that you could get team shot you're
gonna have to be strategic with it I'm
fine with that you know I'm saying like
there's some supers look I'm a dorm
blade dorm blade can be disgusting
because it rewards skill with kill so I
mean a skill but it rewards if you get
killed you go insane it's gonna it last
so I yeah I have to admit and I'm a wall
I mean that one is it lasts so long
it looks really long in PvE you too of
goof around all day yeah I'm gonna like
killing stuff like you see go very
seconds later yeah if you if you chained
a bunch of low-level enemy door red bar
you can keep going and attack the boss
and do dps every way you can do a lot
with that so I got it it is good it
needs to happen
needs to happen especially PV you gotta
feel like you got a shot against because
them spectra blades y'all Titans running
around man it'd be tough to get away
from y'all yeah
near you have a heat-seeking fire fire
Blade 2 and you're yeah I gotta admit
though I was a little disappointed over
know what should be enough - no no I've
got mused enough I still use number one
all the time and I still feel it's it's
very it's very spongy now kids if no
one's using Nova look like that so I was
surprised that one still got hit a
little it's on the low end of the
getting hit but like him I was already
kind of squishy as it is now yeah well
that's my two cents that's it and then
that kind of gets the bottom we've got a
little bit of patch coming there's stuff
about if you have silver on Steam spend
it or on battlenet spending on apps now
I'm coming over
mm-hmm but that is most of it we've
gotten a little tidbit here in the final
segment though shadow keep us so close
so close
what do you wait to get back on that
lunar surface of Leo this is from a
villain or dmg or damage see you next
week when we talk about some exciting
sandbox changes to weapons like SunShot
having 12 in the mag or graviton lance
getting a 30% PvE damage increase whoa
let's go baby
yeah mad daughter out cuz I'm more calm
I mean on PC I don't have the baby which
was the catalyst I don't have it but I
used to have it but I just miss kravid I
love that those were fun buffs when Sun
shot and graviton came up during that
vanilla stage of d2 I felt good and so
to get we got to get them back into me
that was a good gun it was a fun gun so
son shot 12 all right let's go I was hey
that's the biggest thing a lot of people
would say sunshine spunk just doesn't
have enough of the Marek BAM twelve
twelve and now but here's the thing
though they got to give us sources extra
sources for the canvas since there's no
bail when facts
rally's coming back and I miss all that
fly stuff man you know I'm saying so
yeah you know this is this is good
though we got to see what's going on so
yeah next week man we got some more
listen it's like every week they come I
know I know how much more they're gonna
throw at us they've got to run out at
some point but maybe not this will never
select it literally it's next week is
gonna be sandbox changes the weapon so
we're gonna see scout rifle buffs I've
been holding on to some God roles just
for this battle rifle buffs come at some
role I can't wait out out my distant
relation shadow the Polaris lathe I
can't wait to see what y'all gonna do oh
man I cannot wait
this is gonna be fun I got some really
cool oh what'd you call it Scouts that
cannot wait to test out purposely yeah I
know y'all even have to ask you you
probably got the entire scout rifle
collection with four variants per each
with how no all right weapons are really
not as bad I had more armor stone and
scouts I really didn't keep that metal
holder gotta start the podcast with
shout out to my man par-5 the warlock in
the building salute
you forgot forgot about my oxygen bro
and not a yes god but not only that I
got dragon fly speck on that bad boy so
it is disgusting everybody does don't
everybody oh you mean the the mud sorry
you gotta get that bar you gotta get a
dragon ma go get that from there you go
throw that bad boy let me tell you that
it did explosions you dig Sun shot is up
bro that's legendary scout shun Scott is
beast though that dragon fly speckling I
get I'm telling ya everybody hold on to
your dog roll scouts
I'm telling us cows look like they about
to do some serious yeah and uh wait I'm
looking through mine I got em hmm I got
two Jade rabbits in the same night
flower on the other day it's in - audio
I was like what the hell one drowned
randomly and one was the final reward so
I've got Jade rabbit four days I've got
a talons of the Eagle which is
that's good one that's a good one I'm an
outlaw rampage oh you ready you ready
I believe too right oh yeah this I've
got the transfiguration curated outlaw
explosive look I've got a Night Watch
with that sucks
no it's threat detector but it's got
multi kill clip which kind of a trade I
mean I've got I've had like two of the
curated vouchsafe get you got your
Polaris of course do you have your
Polaris catalyst get that popping get
that pop and golden it gonna get me the
hustle gold oh no I know I do yeah yeah
oh noes look it was the weapon mod
something like that hey have perfect
fifth with that explosions real nice but
I can't front man not it prof I've got
me thinking
Polaris might be in the bushes with with
a legendary legendary an oxygen row with
dragon fly up I don't even waste them
I'm not wasting my exotic slot now that
oxygen is what it is so yeah that's
gonna be I think oxygen I was gonna be
giving you our meadow right now give me
your meta game oxygen r3 only well thing
is there's not a lot of solar shields
out there and everything we're about
lighting I don't the press kit Prescott
you got that distillation on deck out
Laura a very small scale cow people gay
guy I see y'all I see everybody's ready
man that's what this is where I love the
meta when he shifts I hold on to those
bad boys those good roles as you know
that time is gonna come and this is time
can't wait for next week now I wanted to
say one little thing
randomly looking through Twitter there
was an undying armor mod screenshot to
potentially get leaked oh let's go
so undying armor mod this will be for
that extra slot cost three energy active
only in the garden of salvation raid mmm
so we do have a raid specific mods which
means kind of seen one before
gain and over shield after you collect
five motes
this modes effect does not stack with
other copies of this mod whoa wait this
is a holy break
gained an over shield after you collect
five motes only active in the garden of
salvation either this is like the wrong
place for a mod to be what it says
enhance the voltaic motes collector
there's gonna be some raid mechanic
dealing with making a motion seeking up
motes that means taken might be involved
geez I don't know I thought I was done
with taken that she's gonna take it
that's a very unique that was weird I
don't know if that's like wrong text or
what but I was just wondering when we
have garden of salvation coming into
mm-hmm coming into it like yeah what do
you think what do you think any any
thoughts on garden of salvation any
wonders hopes opinions like well who I
want to see or what I want to see what
do you what do you want to fight I mean
we're going to the black garden so
you've got vex is taken gonna be messing
with everything or hive gonna what do we
what are we doing well I just Corps was
taking us through so they are converging
there we we have to see why they're
converging why they're being drawn there
why are they seem insistent on
protecting this area with all I seem
like the entire facts race right and
then the vibe I got was didn't Luke
low-key hint like after this like the
remnants of almost like a taken war like
effects was still gonna be around like
the vibe I'm beginning is they are here
for some sort of maybe I'm guessing that
whole arm you know purple was a space
Torito gang
maybe there's some one dude there and
there's some threat there that they are
taking very sick but they when they've
exchanged their directive is they work
like a hive mind like collective mind
did it's something for them to break
protocol they they're taking something
serious it's on we got to figure out why
it's gonna be lit man it's gonna be I'm
excited I love when destiny did this
fantastically were forsaken you know
with the whole barons first we got into
that we thought it was just gonna be
that boom dreama city and this looks
like the same thing in a sense you know
we're gonna start
off eros you know do with these deal
these nightmares he was going on black
God and the thematic change height' what
do you think man what do you what's your
what's your feeling I mean the leak that
I read kind of keeps is what's like
fresh in my mind well spoiler warning is
consumed out now if you want leaks
I mean basically the general idea was
what eros wakes up this is major
spoilers if this is real oh let's go
let's go
heads up to everybody in chat I'll give
you a five-song want to get this baby
down follow us on Twitter twitch Yvonne
cast iron Lords podcast all that good oh
well I guess that we chop and drop a
bombs now potentially what she wakes up
what's causing these nightmares
what's able to awaken all this crap
mm-hm
is a veil ship right that's what I heard
yep that's router also some one of the
veil
so it's this like mystery fifth race
that's way the hell out there so maybe
it's truly a crashed space to reno ship
which sounds hilarious but and that's
what starts raising these guardians that
are floating in there these like
guardian ghosts and raising the
nightmares of what we have killed before
and then it's like oh crap this is what
you guys woke up okay the VEX have to
make sure we don't get wiped out by this
thing that is growing force this
powerful veil that's coming so that's
like the connection between both the vex
and the what's going on on the moon
mm-hmm so then what remains behind well
part of the veil and maybe what comes
next and now we've got season of dawn
dawn of what dawn of the whale dawn of
bad stuff come in who knows I'm with you
all the way up it to the point that we
may be introduced to one aspect of yeah
I think they're they don't be like the
puppet master behind it I don't think
we're gonna yeah right
and I just think we're gonna learn about
it but I can't see them setting up space
debris Toph it's race all the way yeah I
think they're gonna hit it we gonna get
a taste yeah a little clue because it's
the real stories right now yeah yeah
let's be real like ever since we did the
only I mean season Jeff duelists
don't get me started with that trash but
we did see it culminate they kept
hinting space to retail everything keep
seeing space Torino and imagery all over
the place so yeah I think maybe we
finally see a glimpse or whatever
finally in the flesh realizing that that
is the reason and then they probably
keep it in tuk you know from deeply but
my question to you know is before we get
out of here because this is what's
driving me not gonna fit it was driving
me nuts is Aldrin when are we gonna see
him like I need to see Aldrin fam come
on man how long are they go they do is
talking about this collective story and
when the seasons gonna go right into
next season it's gonna be this great
store where's all Jeanette he's around
he's out here moving and shaking when is
he pulling up in the tower and I need my
cutscene with Korra is a violin that's
what everybody's losing their mind that
is next September
Aldrin they're gonna be in hiding
because he doesn't somebody's told him
to go in hiding I'm sure somebody would
just shoot him because they're like what
the hell I was like Mars threat is big
and Prescott had a decent ideas like I
think it's gonna be a season I'm a dying
dawn dusk and night and if you go night
or like season of dawn a season of
darkness maybe is the season of darkness
right before we get to the Vale ships
coming and then it's like destiny 3 your
destiny to subtitle darkness or whatever
they want like it's gonna have to go his
he's on the reef his name is crow he was
crow but that's my guess is he maura the
darkness the veil they are part of the
bigger picture is my lunch I don't think
old ones coming this this year yeah and
then the other thing is we didn't really
get closure with Calais no yeah yeah I
mean unless you as you last the check I
was the once an audience with
what you call it with Mara that's last
time I mean I remember I don't remember
now specifically besides I'm championing
us and you know what do you do I mean
Isabelle is good is he bad is he ever
gonna turn on us or is he like just
using us again they got a progress the
Calais thing and the um you know the O's
ending those are two storylines I would
like to again not that he got a complete
but just advanced you know I'm saying
that that's all I'm saying just advance
it just do we ever get to meet the nine
if there's bacon powerful as we think
they might be or any of them ever going
to be because we had the emissary are we
ever gonna get out on that scale so no
there's there's a lot of unfinished
stories and yeah I want to see all of
them over the course of what's to come
so I'm thinking this will be the tease
of the Vale and then I don't know it's
caught what we're gonna fight in the
black garden have to see so that's the
that was the leak I heard sounded cool
sounded what like waking up that what
would piss off the VEX enough the Vale
yeah yeah that one makes a mess like
that seemed to think yeah most
importantly what is the traveler and
what our ghost lair is like and as the
traveler gonna be around is it awake
because it can help is it gonna fight
the nail is if the veil is that close to
us is it just kind of like vaporize the
moon I mean who knows yeah well we know
from based on a cinema with you know
post Gaul once it we awaken they go you
know space Doritos back in pursuit of
this endless battle that they seem to
have had so Season eleven I think I'm
using yours
Prescott it's gonna be season of
darkness right before whatever next
September is I'm thinking think of that
good stuff all right that's where we
wrap we got through it and not terribly
long okay yeah I mean if you want to
wrap up quick we'll get this thing out
of here nice and smeared
you already know shelter each other
I was outstanding a lot of fun in the
chat today yeah maybe already know me at
Lord kognito on Twitter I am Lord
podcast on YouTube and of course on Lord
podcast every Sunday no longer 1:00 p.m.
Eastern were 11 8 cuz the Lord season
been me to the NFL 6 8 weeks we will be
at 11 a.m. Eastern on the iron law
podcast YouTube channel check us out
this Sunday we gonna be talking about
the latest games we have a special guest
we have the community manager for
warhorse studios it's gonna be amazing
to be talking about Kingdom Come
deliverance he's gonna be talking about
his new game iron harvest we'll also be
talking about the latest and greatest
have been going on in gaming the
Nintendo Direct that was crazy that just
dropped
Geeta's fibers out here that just
dropped you know a lot of moving and
shaking on the tech world you know I'm
giving you our preview right now get an
exclusive don't say kidnapped little X
cloud action so I'm please check us out
and of course really appreciate you guys
with two retweets with Lords of gaming
dotnet you catch articles that I labor
have them I have a last word section I
got my boy up in there to you know go
check them out you don't say so whatever
we I bet you like to give you guys a
preview of some things that we might
discuss just my perspective coming in
you know on a few of the topics that you
know we do and then obviously we get
that print that straight to the campfire
every Friday preferably 9:00 a.m.
Eastern the last word you already know
what my man Yvonne says we give you that
Luther shooter talk and that's what I
got man yeah same with me it's a bonta's
just follow the channel twitter to which
you guys know where to find me even
maybe doing a couple other things over
the course of the next month as we get
ready for shadow keep taking little
breathers here and there and maybe
playing some other things but definitely
follow all of us in all the places we
may have flipped this - a couple Friday
nights depending on yeah schedules are
like and guessing things working on a
couple so if you guys don't see us in
the morning check Twitter we will be
putting up the notifications there so
follow all of us if you don't already
just addy bondus at Lord kognito at last
word pod last word
now follow our Twitter account if you
guys haven't yet for the podcast itself
mm-hmm
so if we do have changes for schedules
for guests you don't want to miss those
because the guests are fun yeah that's
all I got though we got more to digest
next week it sounds like with sandbox
changes coming so another things shout
out to Kevin and chat glad the PC is
running smooth for you another one on
the PC master-race there another convert
nothing that's all so sir will be coming
this will be up on audio so if you guys
don't catch this live check I Tunes
Spotify Google Play any podcast platform
you listen to take us with you on the go
if the videos just a bit too much but
everything else I'm gonna send you guys
over to say hey to one actual cool guy
over there just definitely working on
some PvP stuff I think so thank you guys
very much it has been episode number 72
it is September 6 thank you guys very
much
and for both of us it has been the last
word